three amazing health benefits of
Indonesia obliques or chaga mushroom
chaga mushroom is a fungus that grows on
both trees in cold climates and has been
used for centuries in traditional
medicine for its numerous health
benefits chaga mushroom contains
compounds like betterlinic acid and
certain polysaccharides that have been
shown to inhibit the growth of cancer
cells it is a rich source of
antioxidants which protect ourselves
from damage caused by free radicals
which are unstable molecules that
contribute to aging and disease it's
good for the heart as it lowers
cholesterol due to its high content of
beta glucans it also contains compounds
like triterpenes which prevent cardiac
muscle aging as shown by this scientific
study
also boosts the immune system they do so
by increasing the production of white
blood cells and inhibiting the growth of
fungi and bacteria check out this Chaka
mushroom extract powder which is easy to
include in your daily diet links in the
description remember to stay curious and
stay healthy